siren the Legend of Zelda no we're
starting with Mass Effect Andromeda
trailer okay I'm Greg
that's Brianna hi she makes me feel very
comfortable when she talks that way
Mass Effect Andromeda trailer at e3 2016
are we ready to do this I know oh I know
Mass Effect is just spends so much
galaxy and there's a cause
turning treats this massive effect on
Mass Effect wow that was pretty much how
I operate so here's the idea Mass Effect
was a trilogy of games that followed one
character Commander Shepard
while they she or he saved the galaxy
from the Reapers the one they're called
the Reapers Reapers oh I thought use
they reap what they sow gotcha
technology Shepard is not in this new
game okay but I won't say why even
though everybody knows yes is not quite
a spinoff
supposedly in the same universe totally
but completely different parameters
different story different time just a
different everything except universe I'm
very excited it sounds very exactly what
I thought it would be like yeah pretty
much not been told anything about the
game nothing so far so I'm very excited
to watch it just as anticipated Tory
about this as you should be as you
should be Gregory
wow that's good cause of our survival as
a species has always depended on our
drive to seek out the undiscovered yes I
guess found our limits and expand the
boundaries of our Millah border like
mass effect a wetland or than ever
before what's this a new station to
memory to build a new home for Humanity
okay yeah we need that imagine distance
star systems remotely
teaming alien life and civilizations
amazing worlds where adventure danger
and the unknown are waiting to be
discovered
we created a universe that you'll lose
yourself
I love that I understand everything
that's going up
kind of like interstellar um okay so my
first inclination is well the first
thing I noticed that she goes we made it
yeah nothing makes me think that
humanity had to escape some sort of
tragedy in their last galaxy and had to
come to a new one or spend some time
maybe and now here they are I'm
pondering similar thoughts as you say
them it's weird it's like same same
thoughts at this point you know as much
as I do we both watch the trailer so
this is all extrapolation I know words
like that - I have a big vocabulary
I don't think vocabulary comes does it
okay help me focus so humanity their
choice was interesting to use a female
character they're totally very
interesting I may have read an article
that said that the default main
character is a female where is my last
trilogy it was a male and you could
choose to be a female but I feel like I
hear more about femshep than I do about
a male Shepard which I don't know what
he's called cuz it doesn't matter it's
gonna be hard for me to play this game
because I'm still mourning the loss of
my captain Shepherd right there um just
be excited you need excitement I mean
you can at least speak to how cinematic
the trailer was usually seem [ __ ] I'd
seen another trailer we weren't too
excited I don't know I'm like I don't
know what the hell is going on I'm like
some stuff looks cool but I don't know
what's going on I can't be that excited
for it you gotta be I know I haven't I
don't really know what's going on here
either but it looks so cool space guys
will you understand a little bit
right no no this is all new story like I
said this is completely but you
understand like the world I'm sure it's
a fantastic game I mean does it have a
storyline that's actually interesting
yes it does okay really compelling and
it has lots of twists and turns it's
usually very high stakes and large of
scope understand and I don't want to
compare it to Star Wars because it's a
video game not a movie and exactly well
it'd be fair that our Star Wars video
games Brianna white that's true
and I haven't played them it's like I
can't speak to them what I mean by that
is that Mass Effect is really gorgeously
set in space they really try to push the
limits of technology and trying fight
finding new ways to explore and surprise
you collecting different resources Mass
Effect 2 did a really good job of
allowing you to explore the galaxy Mass
Effect 3 even had more of a big feel I
mean there were just so many worlds that
you could explore with so many different
species and I'm really hoping that they
do an equally good job on this I mean it
feels like they're really gonna try and
expand even more in that even a really
completionist character like a player
like me won't want to go to every single
planet and see everything there is to do
it's almost like they're making it so
that you it's impossible to do that and
that makes me very excited as a game
player for the developers to go into
territory of let's make a game so big
nobody can explore at all I mean how
cool would that be that'd be [ __ ]
awesome right it's interesting to see I
love the insight you give you know and
it's like you take the words right out
of my mouth that's why you have me here
that's is that's why we're reacting to
this trailer Thank You discussing this
trailer cuz I need a buddy who I could
talk about it with right exactly like
some like the camera stops rolling this
is all we're talking about
video games video games and storylines
so yeah this is fun this is funny just
catches hanging out right so the asari
character the blue lady humor her um no
just her face looks so like quirky and
fun and almost like she's got so much
personality just in her facial
characteristics and I'm very excited to
learn more about this character I have a
feeling they wouldn't have put her in
this trailer if she was an integral part
of the game so I'm excited to see where
that goes
what else hmm what else the scene where
the space the little space pods are
traveling from it looked like one ship
to another I was gonna say that looked
really really details really realistic
very good similar observation skills on
par you know the biggest difference that
I see is Mass Effect 3 was almost a
stylized space where is this one looks
like it's going to be a very realistic
space it's not as artistically
interpreted if that makes sense it looks
like they're trying to go for what space
would look like at least from what I can
see and not that makes me very excited
it does because it's just all the more
immersive totally so on board Thank You
Brianna you know speechless hey hey hey
hey you're being annoying you son of a
[ __ ] Todd get away if I'm safer not
knowing anything about this and not
having any real dissipation
my neighbor's my few words I really wish
you omen neighbors because I respect you
so much I would actually be like really
that I would have so my neighbors
absenting my viewers hell um you know it
cut my moment of truth I'm a real artist
well this video is done DM unless
there's more observations there is
always more observations about Mass
Effect well there will always be more to
say no matter what you say it is always
Allah I could go frame-by-frame in that
trailer and find something exciting to
say about each part but well you're
really credit yourself on your
observation skills there that's awesome
I love it I love this game I love this
trailer I love the series it's very
clear that the makers are putting a lot
of love into this my one concern I will
say this before we go my one concern is
that I don't see any of what the
plotline will be and that concerns me
because one of the most important things
in Mass Effect to me was the epic story
it was she was on a mission she might
come in Shepherd she was on a mission to
save the universe the galaxy you know
she was on a mission it drives the plot
forward I didn't get a sense of that in
this trailer so I'm hoping another
trailer will be released a story trailer
to kind of reveal what our mission is
gonna be what our objective is going to
be it's gonna drive the plot line
forward because it's hard to get higher
stakes than it did in Mass Effect 3
where it became a war where you had to
literally politically convince different
races to join your cause it was on a
huge scale and it's gonna be hard to
beat that so I'm hoping they can rise to
the occasion
I can make observations however whatever
I have to say would be the most basic
observations anyone's ever said like
there's good graphics yay always a plus
the action looks cool yes when they
showed the motion capture yeah of that
person flying and then hidden around
that looks so cool
yeah the motion of it looks [ __ ]
amazing and like there's so much
attention to detail yeah I feel like you
can actually be a part of this world ya
know like really feel like you're
actually a part of it whole separate I
feel like this would be this game would
be a great option for virtual reality
oculus rift yeah yeah this game would be
awesome for it I don't think that's
gonna be happening but maybe in the
future I guess my basic observations run
to that no that's why I'm wondering why
you just sitting here being bored like
say your basic observation one time you
brought me on to review something that I
wasn't too familiar with and I said what
I could and that was an interesting
juxtaposition between to someone who
knows a lot about it and someone who
doesn't listen guys I think I'm sick of
saying listen guys yeah you do always
say that [ __ ] hate it actually yeah
subscription services are thank God tea
please use it to subscribe today and
become a reject because man do I have
interesting opinions all the way through
there's a reason this is a movie channel
and not a gaming channel thank you yeah
I didn't want to be the one to have to
say that reverse psychology
but speaking of which I have a gaming
channel what do you know
so if you need more gaming stuff one so
we're gonna let's play us uncharted 4
it's been one heck of a ride so come
check it out on my
channel link will be in the description
below
I figured you'd cut me off you own a
video man you own that you own that
outro on YouTube for 6 months now
alright from our social media now all of
our social media please make sure to
follow us on Facebook Twitter Instagram
vine periscope snapchat all of the above
snapchat right John has a snapchat John
has a snapchat all the links are in the
description below as well it's fun we
post funny things and I just post
modeling pictures and selfies yeah I
primarily post modeling
yeah his bikini pics are on par oh yeah
he riyer yeah I'm always around
beautiful when we do when I'm in my
bikini yeah yeah whose friends